$3,000 at 8% for 6 years so all this is
doing in telling you if you're going to
do this by a table which row which
column so have a look this year says
period because remember it can be years
it could be months it could be quarters
community life but I've kept it nice and
simple so which role I'm going to go
down to the sixth row so here we go and
then 8% is the largest one that's
provided on this table so you're going
to go all the way across and that you
land on this number seven point three
three five nine what do you do we visit
somebody okay I'm going to multiply by
3000 but this is really important I need
to ask you this question because right
now it's clear because you've done
explain recently but in the future when
you have done this for a while you
wouldn't need to understand why do we do
that
why is multiplying by 2000 why not say
add to 3000 or Deline or re4 the power
of what is this what we're doing okay
where can you say that again slowly
because I want to make sure I decide
yeah very good in case I think the
phrase that was that was important when
the MS and I love you apply this with
you as well this is what every single
dollar this is what every single dollar
in the annuity becomes after this amount
of time and add that interest rate right
so every single dollar become this now
remember why that's the case because
that's a lot right this is six years
this is six years so that we know this
is going to be because it is new a TV is
all they're going to put in the one go
up six times right so that's why you're
up six in advance what's the reason for
the discrepancy
what's one bigger than C's good to the
interest right each one of those six
dollars that you put it over time is
going to attract some interest one point
three five
million dollars is what that interest
adds up to okay so beam every single
dollar turns into this then why does
that explain want to do this could you
have three thousand Justin yeah exactly
every single dollar done this and you've
got three categories three thousand
different baby charts this is what each
one of them or two so what's the extra
number if you get like 20 something
twenty two twenty two thousand and seven
yeah I'll just point out cuz I saw it
are you shifting will ask me to check
their stuff and both people have this
presumably because that's exactly what
your calculator ten however this is
currently this is dollars and cents so
therefore we don't need to be told how
we just want to put you should put two
okay even though materially the numbers
have the same value we repent at seventy
cents so we want to make sure the second
decimal place is there okay happy times
now what I want you to think about is
I've said this is present value with a
table the table that I had on the screen
before but we know how to work out
present value by trying to look at the
formula and datasheet and using our for
solitude and using the formulas you find
there whereas it is okay right there
there you go can you see it so the
present value formula is right there so
I can take it equal to now this is the
FV in the future value in their formula
right so I'm going to put that number in
like that now why am i goodbye you guys
what's the right
here okay pledging a knight right there
right to the power 6 okay great so this
is going to give us a different number
go ahead reach the calculator and again
give me two decimal places
what's our out on someone quite a bit
[Music]
13850 eight point five eight four okay
so we'll round down to five eight are
you happy with that so we've used this
alarm what has it like what does it
answer mean we already talked about what
this is seven point three to five
nineteen what is this what is equivalent
to think back to you wasn't no yeah
Monday feedback to you what is the
significance of this number to this
situation
yeah they like I I have that much right
now yep 13,800 and then in this view
with eight percent every single year
yeah that's how much like 22 does this
that we balance I'm going to get
anything you okay yeah very good
so in case you didn't quite catch that
the three times dollars annually means
you better put $3,000 you're going to a
year after year after year it's going to
get an interest and injured what it can
turn into but if you want to do this in
one here without having to repeatedly
put in money if you just wanted to put
in some amount of money and then it just
get that interest for that amount of
time then you get to the same goal to
get to the same end point in the future
and this is what you've got to begin
with and you said this is what you'll be
right now on in order to invest adjusted
utility okay now we've looked at this it
it's not to time to use this however
just like you did up here and use the
table to get this seven point three
three five nine number what I want you
to understand today is that you can use
a table to get is 13,000 even a number
okay so now page two so much which is
large to have a look
for